a story like Vinland Saga is going to
stick with me it's going to stay with
them for years to come hell's Paradise
as it is now I'm gonna forget about it
like in like two years I'm still really
I [__] love hell's Paradise I'm
enjoying the [__] out of that actually I
I think Demon Slayer more like snore
Slayer because it's so boring nothing's
happening I'm like nine episodes in I'm
like can something happen please yeah I
like I like hell's Paradise because I
don't [__] around yeah like it's
happening and Demon Slayer they just
[__] around so much I'm just like just
get to the part where everyone is gonna
start creaming their pants we can have a
10 hour conversation about the nuances
of villain Saga but also the hell's
Paradise is nailing that part of my
brain that's like cool
it is the best like just turn your brain
off yay violence yeah you put it in a
tier yeah above and then you put like
oshinoko and S I was like get okay I
agree with that though no
why don't you agree with that dude I've
been watching all of us shinoco and I'm
like oh my God it's I it's for me it's
like cringe watching it why why the
whole like Terrace uh Terrace House Arc
I was like what the [__] is this [__] I
was like this is wait why was that
cringe oh cause look at that dude's like
the moment where I had I had this you
know you stand up you're like what the
[__] I was like when he like does this
whole like kind of Terrace House like
and if you don't know the Terrace house
there's a whole situation reality
romance yeah it's really unfortunate
situation and it was you know where a a
contestant was on it and they ended up
and like unfortunately committing
suicide from all the mean comments and
the show kind of did like a weird kind
of parody of it I didn't really like and
it was kind of like it was super fast it
was like boom you're on the show boom
you have hate comments now you want to
die and then she tries to die and then
the dude's like stalking her I guess and
it's just ready to catch her and I was
like what the [__] is this what if she
didn't do it is he just following her
this whole time what the hell is this
this dude's a freak that was the anime
moment yeah and I was like and then this
dude
magically I'm sorry dude if you gave me
15 more lives I would not become this
much smarter I'm gonna be realistic
about it this dude became like gigabrain
10 000 IQ social media yeah
so there is a high school version of
Terrace house so they're cut it's like
which is also like I was like what the
[__] is this I was like why are these 16
year olds on a dating show and like I
was just like yeah my Show's like that
in Japan existence I know they do I know
but like I I it was just it was so corny
and and so on the nose I thought it was
really well done I thought it was a
really well done yeah yeah there's
there's few like normally when I see
let's say anime and manga manga
I was gonna say I was gonna say media
and I went MIA anger manga and media uh
Taco like internets kind of like culture
I think it does the best job I've seen
yeah there's still some moments where
I'm like oh this is cringe I feel I feel
like you say that because you are yes
like the industry you know so you know
how things like really really are it's
just how like there's also like another
thing where it was like
the towers House episodes where I really
started getting pissed off I was like oh
my all of this episode is just feels so
stupid and they were like actually don't
worry no need to kill yourself we have
editing it's like what what
everyone's gonna love you now and she's
like no I don't want to kill myself and
it's like what what is this what do you
think mental illness is just an editing
problem like I mean for the TV station
yeah yeah yeah especially in Japan yeah
I mean I thought I I don't think I don't
think it's a mental health thing to make
like and it's like let's fix it do a
tick tock dance let's film it let's get
it going okay I think it's I I got
something totally different because what
I thought was genius about that kind of
Arc was just to show how fickle the
[__] internet which it is yeah and I
appreciate that that was what they were
trying to show and I understood that but
I I guess it was portrayed in a way and
maybe it was because the Breakneck speed
they went through all this stuff yeah
they went through it pretty fast I was
like whoa it was definitely more fleshed
out in the manga yeah because I remember
this this Arc in the manga lasting a
little bit longer did feel pretty fast
in the anime yeah
um so yeah I was like oh I remember
watching the episode and it's like and I
was like oh we'll get into this Arc
already we're getting yeah and I think
that was also a problem with it is that
they were introducing these ideas and
they were running through them so fast
and they're trying to this character are
believable for this girl who you know
because she gets online hate in this one
part we're supposed to believe that
within like just the time frame that was
with flip-flopping sides so often and
it's like what the [__] no I I totally
understand that but I feel like the
ideas that he tried to portray were like
still there
um which is why I still really and we've
interacted with um the Japanese
entertainment industry in various ways
and it is very different to how we
operate uh obviously the agency having
way more power is your thing and also
Japanese hate comments being like Oh
yeah ten times worse oh for sure for
sure Japanese hate comments are intense
yeah uh I don't know just the when I was
watching it I guess it was it was it was
a mixture of the rushed how it was
rushed and I guess because again I work
in what kind of work in that field yeah
I work in that I don't [__] do work I
play video games uh you know it's kind
of I mean interesting it was like damn
all I had to do was do good editing and
make a good video and everyone loves me
again damn phone is that easy for some
people that is that think about think
about think about how maybe some people
get uncanceled sometimes all it takes is
like what all it takes is like the
perfect apology video no no I just need
the one well-crafted video yeah
reputation goes back up yeah yeah and I
guess yeah and I guess sometimes that
does happen like that it's definitely
happened online but there's so many more
cases of like that not being the case
it's never that straightforward and it's
like oh this is a [__] apology video but
in the episode The the YouTuber
character in in that show explains that
yeah and so she's like I wouldn't
recommend you do this video because it
could backfire and I'm like okay you
know they're touching upon the realities
of the internet I mean obviously it's
like dramatized because it's a because
it's because it's a [__] anime
obviously it's drum size but I
appreciated that they were saying things
and I'm like yo that's kind of that's
kind of like that's legit that's kind of
legit that's that's how that's kind of
legit for how things work it's a bit
more dramatic than what we're using
we're super dramatic and I guess that
they were trying to keep that like show
The Dramatics of it but then also not
commit to it because he magically turns
up from stalking her I guess saves the
day which is that was weird right like
he's just he's like following her on the
street yeah
look at this guy's a freak like I do not
like the main character I actually just
I actually don't like them either I
[__] hate this guy so much he's
[__] weird he's like Walmart light
yeah
it's like even like it's oh my God I I
can't stand him and I think that's part
of the reason why I can't stand the show
is that like I do not care for him and
the only reason I watch this goddamn
show is because the opening is a banger
and it convinces me that maybe the show
will be good for five minutes I like it
because of the idea that presents and
the like topics that he explores yeah I
agree with you main character can be is
the least enjoyable character yeah yeah
why'd it be a goddamn [__] basically
an Easter card why couldn't it just why
couldn't they just been so unlikable
goddammit
why do we have to be reborn yeah I mean
I I'm still enjoying Hills Paradise but
it is very much turn your brain off oh
yeah kind of fun yeah and there's only
there's only so much there's only so
much I can enjoy turn your brain off
kind of things yeah I think it unlocks
that part of my brain that really loves
the kind of anime Trope of people the
thing that kind of terraformers gave me
too it's like you get to this new world
when no rules are similar to the world
where you came from yeah but we have
these dudes who are pretty competent and
we can kind of see how they can survive
and how they learn fun because they
learn with you and I really like that
like you I think you mentioned as well
one time it's like the Dark Continent
Arc of Honey Hunter it's like exploring
a brand new world with these [__]
weird monsters and everything's uh no
one gets anything I love that feeling
it's like that feeling of Despair that
the characters feel like oh my God we
have to go up against this [__] like
what the [__] yeah and there's like a
scene where there's like that's not
really scary because it's light spoiler
like there's the this dude's just
walking and then he feels a prick on his
hand on this weird land he just
immediately chops off his house oh yeah
yeah and then I was like that's [__]
sick
it's so soft it's level but I was like
it's true he didn't know what it was he
was like I have this [__] just weird
I'll do it it's just something about
watching a bunch of like [__]
unexplainable badasses doing badass
things
it's just like the rule of cool you know
what I mean where I'm like I don't need
to think too much about this
um I just worry about how much of a
shelf life you can have because it's
like nothing but uh
can't be like really boring after like
one season or something but I think
right now apart from Finland sorry it's
probably the show I'm enjoying watching
the most but I'm only watching like
three shows so yeah there's a there's a
lot of guys so boring I'm I'm I hate
watching Demon Slayer this season I've
decided I'm not even doing that yeah
Demon Slayer uh tried I think the
problem with this season of Demon Slayer
is that what made Demon Slayer great was
the action the really cool animation the
action and then this one was like oh
let's have a bunch of flashbacks to
focus on the characters I it's like
Demon Slayer like you're the the [__]
meme of that kid with the vine or the
the uh yeah it's like Demon Slayer
trying not to insert a flashback
challenge
it's like you should take a shot every
time you should watch demonstrate take a
shot every time there's a flashback yeah
and I feel I feel like there was one
flashback recently where the flashback
actually lasted longer than the [__]
fight I got so pissed off yeah
we didn't watch you for the characters
okay okay I want to spawn something in
the new season because this this thing
pissed me off so much okay and it was
like and I don't know why it pissed me
off it was during the flashback of the
the hashira of the guy that were with
this time yeah and basically I guess to
make him like kind of have a whole Arc
and learn something they just figured
out the best way to make a character
learn something was to just make him
make him have a twin where he's
basically just he's his twin suffers all
the consequences and then that's his Arc
is that he learned from his twin and I
was like they just made another him
isn't it to make him learn the lessons
isn't that a Simpsons Treehouse of
Horrors I think so yeah like Bob's evil
twins it sounds exactly the same it was
like oh he learned all of his story arcs
he would know like I guess there was
consequences he lost his twin but it
kind of felt like they were just making
all the punishment happen to his twin so
that he would learn and it was like
that's a weird like did you just think
what the [__] ah I just thought it was
and also the demons they're fighting are
so boring yeah yeah okay if if there is
another [__] high level demon who
does the [__] Uno reverse colors
like oh no my head is chopped off oh oh
wait wait a minute he's not dead and I'm
like [__] fool me want shame on
me fool me twice this is like the fifth
the fact that the Demon Slayer
characters still get surprised when they
cut their head off and they don't die
it's like
Demon Slayer has become almost like a
parody of itself like in a weird way
where it's like it all the rules they
said just don't [__] matter so so I'm
gonna say this this was this was
recorded when we're at about episode
nine or ten I've already walked up till
episode yeah yeah yeah uh guaranteed by
the time this episode everyone's gonna
change their mind it's gonna be like
this is the best anime of the Season he
did a [__] backflip because DJI we're
gonna get another episode 18. yeah yeah
exactly exactly where I'll be like never
mind this show is golden exactly I the
thing I've learned about Demon Slayer is
that I uh it is a 10 episode handicap
yeah
it is the most boring show for 10
episodes until it becomes good yeah and
then for some reason like it's it's
literally like that Rock Lee meme of
just like taking off the training
weights if this is like the first phase
where he's fighting Gaara and then every
season I'm like dim slay [__] this is
boring and then like you get into the
like the last three episodes and the the
training weights are off and you're like
holy [__] this is golden oh my God that
was so hard and then we repeat the cycle
all over again yeah they know when to
give you the cocaine yeah
it's like not now not now you just get
more and more frustrating you're like
all right take a line now yeah all right
I'm satisfied yeah yeah I mean I the
thing is I'm still watching it I still I
still probably enjoy it I guess yeah oh
man I mean this talk is definitely uh
not motivated me the thing is like like
God's head I think the moment that yeah
and then everyone will be like I'm gonna
wait till the season is over and confirm
that there is another episode 18 moment
and then it was like in The Last Arc
right that the the [__] when they
just went insane with it it was like oh
this kind of I would watch [__] 10
more episodes I think I think the last
talk was the most consistently the best
right yeah it was so good yeah because
there were so many hype moments I think
that I think that Arc was the uh the
outlier because also that hasher was
[__] fun to watch yeah it was just a
delight yeah this hashra [__] snooze
Fest yeah and also like actually like
seeing it was it was this was like
Midway through the previous upwards like
just seeing Nesco kick ass for the first
time you're just like oh my God it's not
just like a cute little anime girl you
know you could you can ask you you can
actually do [__] actually useful yeah
you actually used to use um I I think
this most reminds me of something like
Moog and train or yeah where I was like
this is boring holy [__] this last fight
is hype that I think that I think it's
most similar to something like that so
the other thing I remember from doing in
train is that last fight yeah right the
first hour and a half I'm like what
happened again yeah oh yeah he dreamed
or some [__] and he almost died in a
dream you could literally skip the first
like the four episodes of moving train
I've it's literally like uh compart
comparting into my mind where I'm like I
don't remember this no what happened to
that field and what happened I I
honestly thought because in this season
as well again another spoiler
um the so far uh [__] zenitsu and um
yeah a ball kid I've got his name yeah
yeah no scared
aren't in it and I'm like theoretically
zenitsu's not there should be good now
and it's like oh no this shows always
and this is not in season three no no no
no no oh I gotta watch it it's it's
because I'm showing Mom I don't [__]
know you might show up it's because
instead of being annoying the hashiras
are just boring
that's the the hushers I mean the
[__] girl I can't remember her name
she's just there to uh she's just there
for the fan service
yeah she's she's had like one scene and
I'm like oh you're there for the horny
teenagers yeah I I understand now I
understand why you're there but I have
one there's there's always one there's
always that one
um but no I mean like generally the
anime has been pretty [__] great this
season yeah I'll watch more I just I
haven't had time yeah same that's a lot
is there anything else that's good this
season that I should we should be
looking out for what you what you want
what you what do you mean just tell me
anything what's great
not watching Gundam he's he's not gonna
watch Gundam no matter how good Gundam
gets I'm never gonna he's not gonna
watch Gundam but Gundam has reached that
phase where it's become Gundam again uh
where it's where it's just like oh
here's every war crime imaginable being
committed in one season I'm like oh okay
oh there's covering Japanese history
oh yeah are you watching uh Marshall
what I've read the Manga I want magic
and muscle oh no I wanted to though is
it good I think you'd enjoy that I it
looks like a show that I'd love it it's
probably Vibes right yeah it's one punch
man it's basically just uh one punch man
or mob psycho in Hogwarts oh [__] yeah
yeah basically this gym bro yeah yeah
I've I've seen the synopsis yeah I
wanted to read the Manga but I was like
well I heard the anime is coming out the
monk is good yeah I'm hyped yeah yeah
actually I will I will actually watch
that one yeah yeah that's that's one
definitely for you
um what else would you like we were
getting another Maiden Abyss I kind of
want to see what kind of [__] up well
I mean he has to keep he has to oh yeah
that's right [__] okay okay this one's
this one's this one's on a maybe so far
because I don't know if you'd enjoy I'm
waiting for the season ending to see if
it's worth it okay okay
uh Heavenly delusion okay which is at
the moment is one of the most promised
anime I'm watching out there yeah it's a
lot of promising anime uh but it really
depends on how it ends so I'll come back
to you in two weeks okay tell me in two
weeks yeah yeah we'll see I'll come back
to you this is sounding awfully like
wondering priority right now
yeah
hopefully it doesn't end the same way
hopefully it doesn't end if I've learned
anything from from anime it's that
having a bang of first episode is the
easy part it's it's sticking that stick
in the landing yeah no because with a
show like this so the kind of basic plot
synopsis of this is that it's the it's a
post-apocalyptic world something has app
something has happened to the Earth we
don't know what it's one of those shows
where it doesn't treat you like an idiot
it will show you a little bit of lore a
little bit of at a time and uh you have
all these different elements that you
don't know how they're all connected
there are monsters that somehow roamed
the knights killing people oh I saw your
I'm a big fan of the gig Channel
whenever he uploads our wash uh I think
yeah you you've showed the bit of this
and I thought it would look really cool
yeah
um and like there's like some for some
reason there's like a disease like
ravaging Humanity there's like some
reason there's double gangers that exist
in the world uh and you're like what the
[__] is going on and slowly slowly but
surely it's starting to like make sense
the more episodes go along but it's not
there yet at the big okay this is what's
actually going on so that's what it
depends on but in terms of the
production values I would argue that
it's probably the highest production
value show airing right now for some
reason it's almost like movie level
quality no way yeah it's like chainsaw
man all right level was that without the
CG okay how many episodes left so it's
finished
um so it is about three episodes left
till it's finished okay
um and yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think like keep keep it on keep an eye
on it keep an eye on it it's uh old
school cool cool it's very very good uh
everything else I don't think you'd be
interested in all right
I I know Connor's taste and I'm like you
wouldn't you wouldn't like any of this
stuff
International I think yeah
Marshall uh Marshall was great